Okay, welcome to the DDPS
seminar everyone. Before we
introduce our invited speaker,
let's go over some rules and
logistics. First of all, please
mute yourself during the talk
unless you have questions. If
you have questions, you're
welcome to unmute and ask.
Otherwise, please use chatroom
to post your questions so that
we can address them in q&a
session at the end. Second,
today's DDPS seminar is open to
external audiences therefore no
classified discussion is allowed
for please watch out. Finally,
the talk today will be recorded
and uploaded in our YouTube
channel. That's about it. Now
let me introduce our speaker
today. It is a great honor to
host Ralph Smith, who is a
distinguished university
professor of Mathematics at
North Carolina State University.
He is co author of the research
monograph the smart material
structures modeling, estimation
and control and author of the
books, smart material systems
model development and
uncertainty quantification
theory, implementation and
applications. He is on the
editorial boards of the Journal
of intelligent material systems
and structures and the Siam
journal on uncertainty
uncertainty quantification. He
is the recipient of the 2016
ASME adaptive structures and
material systems prize and SPI e
2017. Smart structures and
materials lifetime achievement,
and he was named a Siam fellow
in 2018. His research areas
include mathematical modeling of
smart material systems,
numerical analysis and methods
for physical systems Bayesian
model collaboration, sensitivity
analysis, control and
uncertainty quantification are
physical and biological systems.
Today, Ralph will talk about
parameter self selection and
active self space techniques for
engineering and biological
models, which is a very
interesting topic. So please
enjoy it. Now without further
ado, let me pass the baton to
Ralph by asking one random
question. As usual. Today's
random question is What is your
favorite things to do other than
research? You can answer this
question and then start the
presentation.
Oh, my gosh, I didn't see that
one coming. Well, first of all,
thank you so much for the
invitation to speak here. I had
to check back I was there in
2018. I had a fantastic visit, I
met several people. And it's
just such an honor to be back
with with this group. favorite
things to do? Well, I have to
warn you up front. And Katie
will maybe smile about this. My
students sometimes told me I
need to get a life. There.
Correct. But I played the piano
since I was five, and still do
some volunteer work there. And I
love to hike. And so one of my
favorite destinations is
Colorado getting onto the
fourteeners the peaks that are
over 14,000 feet.
Oh, wow. You must be pretty good
at piano then. I mean, since you
oh, gosh, it's it's something I
really like. It's just where I
disappear from the science and
and go to the music. So great
question. And thank you. And,
again, thank you for the
invitation. So what I'm going to
do is, gosh, it's the Friday
before break, I'm going to kind
of keep this a little bit low
key in cases. I'll probably stop
at various points to ask
questions. But what I'm going to
talk about are some parameters,
subset selection, active
subspace techniques for large
scale models. And some of this
came out of what was called the
DOE Consortium for Advanced
Simulation of light water
reactors, which was Castle
Consortium for Non Proliferation
enabling capability C neck,
Katie Schmidt is very familiar
with that, as well as some more
recent initiatives. I've got to
be right up front here. I'm
going to say we a whole lot of
times, and we very often it's
not me, it's students, it's
postdocs, it's colleagues. So I
think you can see my cursor,
there's Katie, I'm going to
mention some of what she did on
one slide. But I just really
want to make sure that I
conveyed that we very often was
was other people, not me.
Alright, so I'm going to look at
three applications. The first
one is work that came out of
Castle. This was an 11 year
initiative on large scale
models, and it was focused on
developing next generation model
environments. So here is a nook
of pressurized water reactor. If
you fly into Raleigh from the
south, you'll see Sharon Harris
Lake. That's the secondary
source. That's the lake water.
And then you've got the source
that is up against the the
physics and they're separated.
That's for a reason, just in
case something breaches. So in
the region. In the reactor,
you've got thermal hydraulics,
you've got neutronics, you've
got chemistry, you've got fuels.
So it's very, very large scale,
multi physics multiscale coupled
problem. One of the things cuz
we have to worry about as this
has to be incorporated into
surrogates. And we're worrying
about out of data surrogates
time, time dependent predict the
future. So that's a big deal.
And one of the things that we
did in this was developed what
was called vero, which was a
virtual environment for reactor
applications. So we don't we we,
as in the community, I warned
you about this, this royal we,
the community is focusing
heavily on things like digital
twins, I'll talk about this at
the end, but simulation based
environments to guide
experiments to guide design to
guide some of the reactors
physics, but we're not replacing
experiments. Okay, so one of the
motivations for this analysis is
the 3d neutron transport
equation. So we just finished a
modeling class that I teach, we
know conservation of stuff,
stuff here at neutron transport.
So changing stuff is transport
in. And then all of these
reactions, I've got the segments
are cross sections. So I've got
sources, we've got various cross
sections. And these can be
extremely high dimensional
100,000 inputs, when
discretized. And not all of
those are influential. This is
going to motivate some of the
active subspace. So when I wait,
say we hear this was former
students, Ally, Kayla will point
more to that. We then build the
the surrogate model on the
active subspace, I'll talk about
that. And I point out that some
of the Oak Ridge National Lab
codes take minutes to hours to
run. So when we do things like
Bayesian inference and say, oh,
we need a million simulations,
we have to build a surrogate.
And occasionally, we have that
choice. All right, so that's one
application. The second one,
excuse me is very, very simple.
My modeling class knows this
really well. They just saw it on
their final edits a disease
model. And the reason I'm
pointing to this is a it's been
all over the news for the last
three years modifications of
this were developed for COVID.
Little bit more complex, but not
too much. And it illustrates
some of what we worry about when
we do uncertainty analysis,
sensitivity, analysis, etc. So
we have a population we have
susceptible, infectious and
recovered, that's the SAR, you
start with susceptibles. In the
blue, you have a few infected
here, I started with 100, this
susceptible population decreases
the infected increases. And
here's a model for it. Alright,
so in the model, we have these
two parameters, gamma and K. One
of them is the infection
coefficient, K is the
interaction coefficient. All
right, and the appears a
product. So if we're doing
parameter estimation, these
always appear as a product, I
cannot uniquely define the two
of them. But the reason they
appear in the model is the
interaction coefficient.
Unfortunately, we all know
really well about that. That's
one that we can control, social
distancing, quarantine, etc.
That's one that that we as the
population can control, the
infection coefficient gamma, not
so much. That's a property of
the disease. And so very often
these models will split the two,
because we're very interested in
policies, how do we specify
interactions? And the goal of
sensitivity identifiability
analysis is to say, how do we
isolate a subset of parameters
that we can determine from data
now here, it's trivial, I look
at the model and say, well,
these two appears a product. In
general, we cannot do that.
That's the motivation for what
we're doing. And the third
model, I'm going to point to is
a minimal pbpk model. That's
always hard to say when you're
giving a talk, but it's a
physiologically based
pharmacokinetic model of the
brain.
Minimal because the original
model had 100, ordinary
differential equations and a lot
of parameters. This one has 16,
ordinary differential equations,
everything coupled at 36
parameters. And you've got four
basic compartments, plasma,
brain, lymph and tissue. But in
here, we have a lot of sub
compartments, vascular, various
brain compartments. And the idea
here is to understand headed by
the exposure to proper dosage
regimes. And one of the big
goals in this community is to
take digital twins, which is
everywhere in the engineering
community, and build what they
call virtual populations, or V
pumps. And the idea of a virtual
virtual population is to
determine parameters so that the
model accurately reflects your
population. And that may be
different in different areas,
and then use the model for
virtual testing virtual
simulations. It's safer, it's
cheaper, and then once you have
a prototype or a possibility,
then use that for experimental
testing. Okay, so that's the
third one. The fourth example is
one that I'll carry along that
we've looked at again, I've
worked in smart materials
forever. This yours comes from
density functional theory. And
it's a really simple equation.
It's the Landau energy, it
determines where you have a
complex structure. So here is
lit circulate titanate, it is
the drive mechanism and every
atomic force microscope because
it's extremely precise, however,
it also has led. And so you
cannot use it in the bile in the
body, it's toxic. So there's a
lot of work to say, are the
cliche, can we get the lead out?
Can we replace this with other
materials that are nearly as
good? And what's the Lando
energy does is it says here is
our lead atoms here, oxygen, and
where does this codium Titanium
go and it's stable. At that
point, it's stable at this
point. And it's unstable in
between, we model that with this
sixth order differential
equation where I have a
quadratic with coefficient this
negative so I have a concave
down quadratic, a quartic gets
positive, so concave up quartic
and a positive safestore. And
the question comes up, is this
sort of term necessary? Can we
get along without it? I've seen
papers that go up through 12th
order terms, and I always ask
that question, do I review them?
Are these significant? So the
objective is, can we insert use
uncertainty quantification,
sensitivity analysis, analysis
to bridge the scales? And we'd
love to go from quantum to
system? I'm not sure we'll see
it in the next several years.
But one of the kind of holy
grail inverse problems is then
to say, alright, given a system
application, what molecular
structure do I need, and in this
case, it would be can I replace
lead with something that is less
toxic, but performs nearly as
well. And here's some of the
applications atomic force
microscopy, this appears in most
new automotive carburetors, and
it's a sensor and an airbag.
These are both sensing and
actuating. Okay, so there's some
of the applications now, where
we often go, and this is really
Elementary, we're at the end of
the year. So very elementary,
when I teach modeling, the first
place, we start when we develop
a spring equation is a linear
constituent relation. Stress,
which is sigma is proportional
the strain, lowercase E, with a
proportionality constant often
goes by the Young's modulus, it
depends on the units, but
capital E. And then we also have
velocity dependent damping. And
that makes sense if you ride a
bike, the force of the wind is
going to be more if you're
riding faster, I ride pretty
slow now. So that's not such an
issue. But you've got damping is
proportional to velocity d EDT
with a coefficient C. And I'm
going to take nominal values, my
modulus I'm going to take to be
100. I'm not worrying about the
unit's damping coefficient point
one, a typical strain is point
1%. So point 001. And I'm going
to take the strain rate of point
one. And the question would be,
to which parameter modulus, or
damping is the stress most
sensitive. And the place we
would often start is to say,
Okay, let's just look at the
derivative of my response with
respect to the two parameters.
So derivative with respect to
capital E, well, that's just the
strain is point 001. Derivative
with respect to damping. That's
point one. easy conclusion, more
data more sensitive to damping.
There's a number of limitations
to this. It does not accommodate
uncertainty. It's just
derivative. There's no just but
its derivatives doesn't
accommodate potential
correlation. And it's really
sensitive to units. And that's a
big deal, we often will switch
units or magnitudes. So the next
step on that would be say, All
right, let's take a slightly
more global perspective. And,
again, this is just repeating my
problem, I've got this linear
model in values, and I'm going
to vary my parameters 10%, about
the nominal values, I'm going to
choose a uniform distribution.
And my nominal for the modulus
was 100. So I'm going to vary
between 90 and 110. Similarly,
vary the damping. And let's just
plot what we get for our
distribution. So sigma, would I
do that as a function of V
varies from point 1.12. And it's
got a really well defined mean
value here. On the other hand,
sigma is a function of damping
varies from it's hard to tell
here, but one Oh, something up
very much. There's a lot of
spread, but the mean does not
vary much. And so we would say,
oh, from this global
perspective, where I'm sampling
on the distributions, the
response is not very sensitive
to damping, but that directly
conflicts with what we saw for
local. So this, I hope,
illustrates one of the issues.
All right. So how does one do
this and this is we as in the
community, this often goes by
Sobel analysis, or variance
based analysis. It's frightening
how many times we as in the
community has thought, Oh, we're
going to develop this new rule.
ation, and then you look into
literature. And so we'll publish
it with a comment of this
follows kind of obviously, he
was just a, a true leader in
this field. So what we would do
there is take our parameters,
uniform, I'm going to assume
independence. So I'm just going
to say, All right, let's just
take my space to be 01 to
whatever number of parameters I
have, and we expand it in a
series. So I have my response is
a mean value, and first order
interactions, and so on. So we
look at a series, the analogy on
this would be tailor or more
more fit for you. And with
foria, we know we have to have
some kind of constraint, the
constraint is we take orthogonal
bases sines and cosines. And we
have to have constraints here.
But what we do when we do do
that is I have my mean is the
average. So that's pretty easy
to see, if I go 01, I integrate
over 01. And there's the
average, that's easy to
calculate the problem is a p
dimensional. And for example,
with the pharmacokinetic, model
p was on the order of 16. I'm
integrating over r 16. And
suddenly, we start to see one of
the extremely big challenges of
this type of sensitive analysis
is high dimensional integration.
The first order interactions are
integrate over everything except
that variable. So there's tilde
it says, integrate over
everything except that variable,
subtract the mean. And the
reason people do that is you can
then form the partial variance.
And when you square this, you've
got basically the mean squared
minus the average of the entire
thing squared, and the total
variance, and you form what are
called sub lunacy, which is the
ratio. So with this expansion, I
immediately get the partial
variance, total variance. And
the way you would interpret that
is to say, Okay, back to this
example that I just looked at,
I'm looking at the variance of
the mean, it goes from point one
up to point one, two, it varies
more for this example. And that
isn't intuitive, I hope
explanation of why people would
look at this method. Now,
independent parameters, kind of
keep that one in the back your
mind. All right, this is a kind
of a more technical side, I'm
not going to belabor it. But you
can do this more generally using
multi index notation, integrate
up through all of your variables
and say, Okay, this, what looks
like an absolute value is just
the magnitude going from one up
to p, integrate over all of
these. If they're independent, I
should have put that part in red
too, then I can write down the
variance in terms of these
partial variances and write
Sobel indices. So it's a really
elegant way to write this for p
variables. Again, I showed it
for two. This slide, this takes
it up for P. I bought don't want
to belabor the notation, but
there we go. Okay. Um, to quote
one of my very good friends,
Allison Wilson has statistics
here. What could possibly go
wrong? Okay, and that doesn't
even laugh. I didn't even read
that on that level. So let's go
back to our model for quantum
informed continuum model. It was
this
quadratic, or quadratic with a
negative coefficient, CORDIC,
and six order. There's the plot.
And we do this sensitivity
analysis, aka three parameters,
alpha one, double one and triple
one. And the Sobel indices, for
the first two are an order of
magnitude bigger than for the
third one. And they add up to
one that's kind of a big deal.
Because that says, we've, we've
accumulated everything. Here's
the total, the add up to one. I
didn't say anything about Morris
indices, this is an average of
the derivative. The difference
there not so much. Point? Oh,
7.03. Not sure I'd want to make
a decision based on that. But
based on Soble, point three,
nine versus point 01. We'd say
that alpha 111 is insignificant,
we fix it for future analysis.
And off we go. Except what would
Ellison say What could possibly
go wrong? So here's what
happens. So we perform a
Bayesian inference with
different distributions. And
when we vary all of them, I get
this blue. That's what I vary
all the parameters. And then I
fixed alpha 111, which I said,
Oh, the analysis says it's not
influential, that means that it
doesn't really impact our
response. And I get very
different results. And what that
says is something went wrong,
it's not really non influential.
What went wrong? Well, remember,
I kept kind of saying, with the
assumption of independent, kept
kind of going back to that these
parameters are dependent to
correlated. Here's the pairwise
plots and I've got a very strong
negative correlation between
alpha one and alpha one one,
positive blue between alpha one
and alpha triple one. And we
just totally ignored that. And I
love pointing this example out
to my students of if you ignore
your hypotheses, things can go
badly. And here's where it went
badly. Okay, so how do we Get
dressed this well, there are
extensions to this general
formulation. And again, this is
with this multi index notation
that accommodate the covariance
structure. That's really cool.
The problem is you can get
negative indices because
covariances, that one's gonna be
negative. And so you can get
negative indices from this. And
it's really hard to interpret
negative indices, because we
were just going on the fact that
they add to one, but negative
just really makes it hard to
interpret. It's often difficult
to find the underlying
distribution. And you have to do
Monte Carlo approximation, which
is often extremely expensive.
Okay, so there's some issues
there. What do we do alternative
parameter subset selection, I'll
talk about that. Active subspace
techniques. And both of these
accommodate parameter
correlation. So that's where
we're headed. So what I'll do is
I'll talk about parameter subset
selection, and then stop for
questions. So the motivation on
parameter subset selection is
back to our model to the very
simple disease model where I had
this interaction coefficient and
infection coefficient. The four
parameters are not uniquely
determined to database by data
because they appears this
product. And I look at an
observation model, we always
come back to the observation
model, it's the same place you'd
go for Bayesian inference. And
I'm taking the infected, which I
just planted here. That's my
infected cool thing. I assume
that I've got measurement
errors. All right. So I've got
data, which is plotted as the
blue dots, the solid line is the
model. And then I've got
observation errors. And there's
a lot of sources for this,
especially with the D disease
bottles. Did people actually
correct did they do their COVID
Test accurately.dot.so, we start
with this observation model. And
then we make the statement or
observation, not the statement,
the observation that non
identifiable or non influential
parameters and those that have
minimal influence on my model.
And again, in a previous case,
that was the infected
individuals. So pictorially, if
I am doing this around the
nominal value, theta star, and
at the turbot, I see very little
difference in the slope. Well,
that was what we just looked at
for local sensitivity analysis,
so that that's intuitive. If I'm
looking at two parameters, the
level curves are about the same.
So the motivation on this is to
say, alright, let's consider a
Taylor expansion, it always
comes back to this for nonlinear
models about this nominal value
theta star, I could get that
either from optimization, or I
can do this with simulated data.
And I've got the perturbations.
This is the gradient and
perturbations. And then we look
at the functional bits, the
difference between the data y i
and a model, that's just the
least squares. And again, we can
do this with optimization, but
we often use we often use
synthetic data. So there's the
the motivation, do a parameter
subset, or do a Taylor
expansion. Okay, this slide is
busy, but a lot of it's
repeating, I did my Taylor
expansion, I've got this least
squares functional. Now, what we
just said is, if this is a
nominal value, and I'm
minimizing this functional, Wi
Fi is pretty close to the model
at the nominal value. Either I
generated synthetic data that
way, or I optimized. So if I
look at my gradient here, this
value right here is very close
to why I left with the gradient
times of perturbation. So my
perturbation in in J, which is
the functional is approximately
the gradient times the
perturbations, quantity squared.
All right. And what we can do is
rewrite that in terms of the
sensitivity matrix S. Okay, so
what is that going to be s is
the derivatives of my model with
respect to theta one, theta P,
at different time values. I'm
going to come back to how we
calculate that but there's a
sensitivity matrix. And its
sensitivity matrix transpose
sensitivity matrix that is this
product. All right, here's
another bit of the intuition.
We'd say, Okay, this is my
penalty functional. Remember
over here, we're looking at
cases where the values are
pretty close level curves are
derivatives. So I say alright,
let's express J in terms of
Eigen vectors and Eigen values
of S transpose S, which is the
scale Fisher information matrix
incorporates parameter
correlation. So remember, if
that's the case, I've got S
transpose S, take that to be an
eigen vectors, lambda times the
value and that just says it my
penalty is eigenvalues times the
square. Okay. So if our Eigen
values were approximately zero,
perturbations were approximately
zero It's not identifiable.
That's the intuition. That's the
picture I just drew right here.
Cool. All right, so we're
looking at an eigenvalue
problem. Now a little bit of
history on this computing eigen
values of S transpose S, if you
talked about linear algebra
colleagues a sort of standups.
Drake, because you get small
Eigen values, it's more
numerically efficient to instead
look at the singular value or QR
of s, rather than S transpose S.
that have history. There's this
beautiful paper by Reed in
1990 77, he was in the control
community, reset o parameters,
data are sensitivity
identifiable, if S is one to
one, or the null space of S
transpose S is S, it goes back
to 1977. All right, getting to
point to Katie and some of her
work from 2016. She looked at
parameter subset selection for
mixed effects models. There's a
beautiful paper that she wrote
in the International Journal of
uncertainty quantification. This
is mixed effects I won't be able
to talk about but it's really
important talk to her about
this, it's when you have
individual effects in a
population. So there's a bit of
the background. And back to our
SR model, we do this, we look at
the rank, it's three. And that
makes sense, because of these
four parameters. Gamma and k are
not totally identifiable. Okay.
However, there's no free lunch,
it requires gradient
approximations. Because I've got
this sensitivity matrix. And
it's local. Alright, so let's
talk about the gradient
approximations. And this is
perhaps the coolest, next two
slides of the talk. We're going
to use complex step derivative
approximations. And this goes
way back then it's discussed in
a paper by Lanessa molar, I
always have to point out to my,
my students, that molar was the
person who basically invented
MATLAB in 1967, where they
looked at analytic functions.
And basically what it says is,
if you have a smooth F doesn't
have to be analytically smooth,
and you do a complex
perturbation, rather than a real
perturbation. Look at the Taylor
series on this, you get the
following Taylor series, and
then you approximate the
derivative f prime by the
imaginary part of this
perturbation divided by h. And
when you do that, you've got an
order h squared error. All
right, so there's two things to
notice about this.
There's no subtractive
cancellation, if I did a Taylor
expansion, I've got f of x plus
the perturbation minus f of x
limits its accuracy. The Taylor
expansion is also order h. So a
really classical example is to
say, alright, if I do a finite
difference, I'm order h, it's
this black line, until the
square root of machine epsilon,
and then I come back out, and
it's inaccurate. This
approximation is order h
squared, until you get to
basically machine epsilon, and
then it stays there. There's no
subtractive cancellation. It's
incredibly robust. We use step
size at 10 to minus 14, which
you could never ever do with a
finite difference. And I have to
believe so this is a 1967
reference, I have to believe
this is something that someone
like Fourier looked at and
thought, yeah, that's really
cool. And then didn't even write
it out. But it's really, really
impressive when it works. Okay,
so I'm going to illustrate this
on the MPB PK. This is work by
camaleon data, Shoba 16, ODS, 36
parameters. And one way to
verify this is compare complex
step for your sensitivities and
sensitivity equations.
Sensitivity equation, you
differentiate your model with
respect to the parameters. It
took her several days to code,
the sensitivity equations, it
took her about 15 minutes to do
the complex stuff. And the match
the very, very close. And it
requires two lines of MATLAB
code, you take a complex
perturbation, and you keep the
imaginary part. The accuracy is
dictated by this od solver. It
doesn't always work. And if
you're using things like the PDE
toolbox, they have analytic
function capabilities, but when
it works, it's really really
really cool. Okay. Back to her
problem, this is the parameter
subset selection for this
minimal model. She considered
five dose regimes. It turned out
from the 36 parameters non were
nine were non identifiable. So
then the verification on this
was randomly sampled the
remaining ones fixed the non
identifiable and this is a
visual comparison. So all of
them randomly sampled, fixed the
random and you get a very close
match. Hey, that's parameter
subset selection still local,
but It is a very, very powerful
way to look at these types of
problems. Okay, so I'm going to
spend the remainder of the time
talking about active subspaces.
They look similar. But it might
be good at this point just to
see if there's questions. And
then of course, we'll entertain
questions at the end. But this
is kind of the end of part one.
But let's, let's see if there's
questions at this point. Okay,
and let's see, it's a little
hard for me. Let me see if I can
do my chat on the other side.
I can, I can press it. Okay, so
the ROB as about okay, Ralph,
it's just uh, oh, she's very
brilliant. And that said, can
you expand upon the methodology
limitations? Yeah. Seems to have
a general applicability.
Yeah, no, no, that's a great
question. And great to see you,
Rob. Yeah, it doesn't, it's not
a panacea for everything. So the
original formulation required
analytic, the Taylor expansion,
you still require smoothness,
but it doesn't have to be
analytic. It, people have pushed
it up to disk continuities, and
it does well, up to this
continuity, you have to be a
little bit careful about some
coats. So for example, the
absolute value in some languages
is the modulus. And the modulus
may be interpreted slightly
differently be a little bit
careful there. In MATLAB, we
have found it to be really
robust, but places where one has
to be pretty careful our PDE
toolbox, it will have trouble
because there's analytic
function capabilities. The
neural net toolbox also has some
complex algebra in it. So one
has to be a little bit careful
about places where you have
those types of limitations. But
as long as the complex algebra
is robust, it's been pretty hard
to break. The thing that we
always always advocate is
verification, verification,
verification, all of my students
are hurt postdocs have heard
this, compared to another
method. But it is pretty hard to
break. And it is starting to
gain more traction. A little bit
more of the history. So this one
was the first place I've seen a
reference. The aerospace
community picked it up in Gosh,
around 1990s and used it pretty
heavily there. Tom banks used it
pretty heavily in math biology,
about 12 years ago, it is
gaining traction, but verify.
That's that's some of the
limitations and ideas on it. But
a great, great question.
Ralph, we have one more
question. Do you have time to
absolutely yeah. Could you read
it? Yeah. Is there another
question from Mark? How does a
complex perturbation affect
things like adaptive step size
in od e integration? Operating?
Oh,
gosh, yeah. Great question.
Yeah. So I made the comment that
the accuracy is dictated by the,
the accuracy ote solver, it
doesn't really affect it. So if
you set a say absolute error in
your od solver of 10 to the
minus five, you're going to get
the results you're looking for.
And I think that was okay.
camallo is usually about 10 to
the minus 10. Here, it does not
affect that at all. And again,
we typically use a step size on
the order of say 10 to the minus
14, we go small, try some
others, but it does not affect
the ote solvers. They seem to be
very, very robust with respect
to it. So well, let me gosh,
great questions. And I just,
again, I sort of preface this
may be this is really cool.
It's, there's an old adage, if
it sounds too good to be true,
that may be the case. This one
is pretty good. All right, let
me talk a bit about action
subspaces. And then we can talk
in general equation. So this
looks similar, but it gives you
subspaces rather than subsets.
So here's an example from Paul
Constantine's book. It says
linear combination point seven
q1 point three q2, exponential.
And obviously, they're linearly
related. So here is the linear
subspace, there's no variation
in the orthogonal direction. And
so what we would do is look for
these subspaces, and put all of
the heavy lifting onto the
linear algebra techniques.
Alright, I always like pointing
out history because this is very
often incorrectly attributed to
Rusi. And around 2010. Paul
Constantine did an amazing job
of conveying this to the
community in a way that just I
think showed its strengths in
addition to what Ruthie did
remember that paper by Reed, I
quoted it right before I quoted
Katie stuff. This is the same as
an identifiable subspace
locally. That's a big
difference, but locally for
nonlinear problems, and if it's
a linear problem, like that
one's hard because it's SVD and
QR and I had to do some
searching. There's this
beautiful review paper in 1993
by Stewart the talks about SVD
QR, but I hope this gives a hint
that finding these subspaces
puts all of the heavy lifting
onto the linear algebra and
these are these are amazing
techniques. SVD QR R incredibly
robust. Okay, so this one's a
little bit mathy. We'll get to
some examples in a few minutes.
So I've got a nonlinearly
parameterised problem. I've got
gradients, we just talked about
that. Paul has a beautiful Siam
frontiers book in 2015. Bureau
and clean Webster, International
Journal of uncertainty
qualification, same journal I
mentioned for KT earlier paper,
and you construct an outer
product, gradient gradient and a
distribution that's kind of a
big deal. Let me go to the next
one. How tip sensitive are the
results of this distribution?
Not very, but tested. And this
gradient gradient, Oh, this
looks a lot like parameters
subset selection, except for
averaging it. Okay, I'm going to
describe this in terms of Eigen
values, because I just motivated
parameter subset selection that
way, but we typically do it in
terms of the singular values for
the reasons I mentioned. But for
the Eigen values, I look for a
break, talk a little about that
breaking the eigenvalues, split
the eigenvectors at that same
dimension. And that gives me a
subspace of active variables and
the complement of the inactive
variables. So small Eigen values
are inactive, small singular
values inactive. Okay, so the
algorithm on this and then we're
going to get to a bit more of
the examples are, we have to
discretize this, and this is
kind of a big deal. This is.
This is where the Monte Carlo
sampling comes in, we would
typically only form the
sensitivity matrix, we talked
about that for parameter subset
selection, cake, the SVD. And
look at the first n dimensions.
Right? It's tempting to find a
differences. It's not effective.
It just it's not accurate enough
at high D strategy is employed
complex step ingredient free
algorithms. Here's where I'm
going to point to we being Ali
and Kayla. And the example that
they looked at was back to the
nuclear example, I promised
those can come back to that this
is the nuclear example we're
looking at at dimension 7700.
It's not 100,000. But it's
pretty high dimension. And we
look at k effective, and k
effective determines whether
reactions go forward, or they
don't k effective greater than
1k, effective less than one
forward, if it's there. When you
discretize, your reactions,
these are all again, cross
section, fishing cross sections,
etc, etc. And materials, you've
got 7700. And I just point out
that these cross section
libraries are binary, and you
have to do a conversion. And
that was something that on the
math side, we had to be really
careful about that. Again, we
being Ellie and Kayla here. So
the results on this, were to
say, all right, 7700 skill
evaluations, this was the code
we're using gradient based
required 1000. The algorithm
that they used required 18,000.
And projected Finite Difference
projected finite difference was
7 million, we couldn't do it
because you just don't have the
computational budgets for that.
All right. And this one's a nice
test problem, because you have
analytic eigen values of one and
01 is the reaction proceeds zero
is it does it the black or the
gradient based, the red are the
initialized the new algorithm.
And you have one eigenvalue one,
and then you see it drops to
zero. And it turns out that this
new algorithm was more accurate.
And the reason for that is
computing converge, that joint
solutions was often not
achieved. It's one of these
things where the code that
people will say, Yes, we have an
adequate code. But getting them
to converge is hard. All right,
so what was it imagine that
started at 7700, we would use
gradient based which gave a
dimension one active subspace,
we went from 7700 to one
principal component analysis was
either two or one depending on
the cut off. And for surrogate
sampled off for a tolerance of
10 to the minus three, it's a
one dimensional subspace to if
you go higher, that is a big
deal. We go from 77 to one and
building a circular one D is
really, really easy. So that's a
very large scale example. Now,
the last five minutes I just
want to talk about Bayesian
inference here and where we
might use that so back to Paul's
example. This linear combination
points seven times first
parameter points three times a
second, they're not jointly
identifiable. So what we did
this being we was Ally was took
uniform distributions in black.
And the reason you take uniform
is when you rotate a uniform,
it's uniforms. I'm sorry, the
reason we use normal
distributions. I said uniform I
meant normal is when you rotate
a normal you stay normal. Okay,
so the normal wasn't black. And
we just did it using different
see how it works. And when you
find is the full space looks
like it's informing the first
parameter, not so much the
second. And when you look at the
pairwise you get exactly this
non identifiable subspace.
Here's the pairwise plot, it's
single value that indicates four
points on this line. They give
the same likelihoods. They're
not identifiable. And that makes
sense. There it is. Okay, so
what we want to do is say, can
we use active subspaces? To
understand and do Bayesian
inference? And you can. So
here's the example from the
gradient matrix. We've talked a
couple of times about that. Take
the SVD. Here's my singular
values, corresponding singular
vectors. And either the Eigen
value or a singular value
indicates a one deactive
subspace, and here would be the
basis for it. Point nine. All
right. So if you do inference on
the active subspace, what you
would do is say, Okay, I've got
a 1d active subspace, I sample
values on here, and fit a
response. Okay, so there it is,
I've got training points in red,
I fit my model to it. It's an
exponential. I have test points
in blue. So I construct and
validate, verify, perform
Bayesian inference on this one D
subspace? Gosh, it's Bayesian
inference on 1d. That's easy.
Because it's invariant, we can
just randomly draw to fill out
the 2d space from normal 01. And
then we transform back because
when we work with the nuclear
engineers, they don't care about
Transform Variables. They want
physical variables. Okay. Final
step did we look at on here? Is
they okay, we did the inference?
How do we understand this a
little better? Well, here was
the prior in black, the first
patient to reduce space,
restrict what we get for the
first parameter, not so much for
the second. And to get a
sensitivity measure on that we
go back to work that Paul
Constantine did and said, Well,
what you can form are these
activity scores, which are
either either eigen or singular
values, and vectors, and look at
the squares of the components.
So I just said, Oh, on the
previous slide, I got the point
nine, one for the first point
three, nine for the second, I
square these, the first one is
going to be influential is going
to be informed during inference,
the second is not, and the
results show that. Okay, let's
look at a real example. And
finish with questions. So a
little bit more mathy. It's a
family of elliptic equations,
this could be acoustics, it
could be groundwater flow,
whatever your favorite thing is,
you can think about groundwater
flow, and on a rectangular
domain, and various heights. So
I have elliptic differential
equations. Again, this is steady
state. So groundwater flow
acoustics, you can look at
electromagnetics. And I have n
different heights, I have a
random field a. So I represent
it in terms of a cartoon and law
of expansion. Think for a if you
haven't seen that, but I just
represented, and my quantity of
interest is going to be the
strain at the n different
levels. So I integrate and get
the strain at these n different
levels. There's the model. When
you do your expansion, in terms
of the cartoon on low F, my
dimension is 91, it's pretty
high dimensional. The active
subspace dimension is three
because I constructed that way.
And this is a fun element
discretization on it. Alright,
so we look at our singular
values. And remember, we
constructed it with three, if I
look at the singular values,
I've got three that are almost
two orders of magnitude larger
than the others. And that we
this was a verification, we knew
that by construction, we then
construct the activity scores,
and there's three of them that
are again, gosh, two orders of
magnitude larger than the
others. And they correspond to
parameters 138 and 66. So what
this says is those parameters
will be informed during Bayesian
inference, the others, not so
much. So 138 and 66. Okay, we
being ally, and, and Brian on
this. So again, the prior is the
black Gaussian priors in all
cases, here is not sure why
switch order but 3866 and one,
in all cases, the posterior is
much narrower than the prior. So
and the reduced space, this is
the we get on the active
subspace. Here's my posterior,
much more narrow than the prior.
We've been doing a good job on
this. Just to test this. Le then
said let's take parameters 4068
and six n three. And here what
we find is doing inference on
the reduced space. You do not
inform your priority All that
means that you're just getting
no identifiability. Here. In any
of these cases other than the
space, the full space looks like
it is. And that's erroneous. And
we asked, why is that? And just
to point out the full space
computations took 18 hours to
reduce space to 20 seconds. It's
a big time difference. And
here's the full space 18 hours.
The chains are sort of
converging, but not really.
You've got the stagnating
regions. Here's a stagnating
region. Here's a stagnating
region here. It's not terrible,
but the full space inferences is
not reliable. Yet of subspace,
I've got a colleague here named
Brian rich, and every student in
my class and his nose. You look
for chains that look like fuzzy
caterpillars. And the ears, your
fuzzy caterpillars. These chains
look great. Yeah, can subspace
is doing what it's supposed to.
We're informing three of the
parameters. The remainder are
not we go back to the nuclear
engineers and save. That's what
you can do with this model.
Okay, let's, let's get some
concluding remarks answer
questions discuss. So premiere
sub slash selection, really,
really nice to identify to
isolate identifiable influential
parameters. And it accommodates
parameter dependencies. I didn't
really emphasize this, but it
focuses on if you do the Eigen
values, it's a Fisher
information matrix. If you can
invert that. It's proportional
to the covariance matrix. So it
accommodates dependencies. At
can subspace, this is a subset
subspace builds a subspace of
these. And you can go very high
dimensional, complex step, gosh,
give it a try. send me email,
I'll send you references. When
it works. It's really, really
good. We live by surrogate
models, that that's sort of just
a given, we often use that our
computational budget to
construct and verify. And then
we work with that. Um, I want to
kind of just get on my control
background, soapbox and say,
well, the synergy between what I
talked about uncertainty
quantification, sensitivity
analysis and control design. And
so that's one of my big pushes
right now is to keep bringing
some of these two areas
together. I've mentioned virtual
twins and virtual populations
and so on. Gosh, this goes back
to probably that will not
probably NASA with Apollo 13 was
the first place that a virtual a
digital twin was used, where
they took data, they updated
their models, they provided a
set of instructions to bring
back Apollo 13. It's huge right
now. For everyone who's been
following Artemis, they're doing
digital digital twins hear. It's
pretty much everywhere in
engineering. My colleague Nam
did a nuclear engineering has
built a beautiful scenario for
building a digital twin of a
nuclear power plant. For parts
that are hard to test. One of
the places we're looking at is
the Marksman turned Russian. And
probably a good place to stop
here is prediction is very
difficult, especially if it's
about the future. Because you're
extrapolating. I'm old. I first
heard Yogi Berra say this. And
he did. But Niels Bohr said at
the same time, it's a Danish
proverb. But here's what we're
going is out of we're doing
extrapolate story predictions
out of data predictions. These
are the types of predictions
we're looking at. Okay, so
there's an overview of these
topics. I'd love to entertain
questions. Again, thank you so
much for the chance to being
able to visit with you all and
let's just open up for general
questions now.
Thank you. Thank you so much for
the wonderful talk. Yeah, let's,
let's do the q&a session.
Yeah, if you can read the chat.
It's, I've got it over on my
laptop, but it's kind of weird.
But if you can read that, and
then just unmute yourself and
say, hi, and let me know
questions that way as well.
Exactly, exactly. Yeah, please
feel free to unmute yourself.
And, you know, speak for
yourself. Yeah. I don't have any
questions in the in the chat
room.
Okay. Let's unmute. And let's
just open up to general
discussion. And one of the ones
I wanted to the virtual, the
digital twins that I actually
usually goes by digital twins
and virtual populations, I
should probably correct that.
But are people that are working
on that? Because again, it just
seems like a special issue of
every engineering journal right
now is focused on this.
Yeah. As a matter of fact,
emphasis a couple of, you know,
the internal funding projects at
Lawrence Livermore National Lab,
it's, it's all about digital
twins. So there are folks who
are working on the digital twins
and and many, many folks who
work on the digital model,
including me, it's that's the,
you know, that's aiming for the
digital twins as well. Right.
It is and, and one of the things
that I often point out and
again, you guys are working on
this and more ground zero But
I've had colleagues say, well,
it's just model calibration.
I've been doing digital twins my
whole career. But the place
where I look at is somewhat
different is, it really is
you're really building unique
models for a specific entity.
And it's also some beautiful
kind of incorporations of
machine learning to say, Where
do I collect the data, and
collect new data that I need in
order to update that. So for
those who may not be familiar
with it, it it really goes
beyond model calibration to this
incredibly complete picture of
how do we build a numerical
representation for a specific
entity, and updated as entities
as it's like progressives? But
yeah, I'm talking too much. I
want to hear hear from you guys.
All right.
Sounds good. Okay. I can ask
questions. So one of the topics
you cover was active subspace
methods. And you successfully
apply that for, you know, the
examples with a parameter space
of, you know, 7700, as you
indicated in this in this slide.
It's a, it depends on the
successful application of active
self space is dependent,
depending on that activation,
you know, the factor how much
you can truncate and still get
the good representations using
the gradient? And if that is not
the case, then active subspace
will not work, right.
Yeah, no, you're absolutely
right. I mean, it's, it's based
on linearization. And gosh, so
many of these methods for
nonlinear problems are based on
linearization. So you really
want to try and get the
linearization as accurate as you
can. And for a lot of the codes
we've looked at, they do have
ADD joints. And that would be
the immediate place we'd start
with would be an edge joint.
That's where I wanted to point
for to complex step and some of
these other approximation
methods. But no, you're
absolutely right. It, all of
these methods for nonlinear
problems depend on the
linearization. And you want to
get that as accurate as you can.
Right. Right. Yeah. And another
extension would be is, is there,
you know, nonlinear version of
active active space?
Yeah. Okay. I'm gonna take that
question and pose it as a future
question for the community. So a
sort of a nonlinear version is
parameter subset selection. And
again, we're still calculating
gradients. But we're not doing a
subspace, parameter subset
selection is local. Right now,
it's at a point, the obvious
thing to try is averaging it.
And we did. And sometimes that
works, but you can also write
down counter examples. But But
no, I think there's a lot of
work to be done on extending
this to parameter subset
selection techniques. Again,
it's a linearization. But it's a
different philosophy looking for
subsets rather than subspaces.
As far as going with the
nonlinear itself, I, in specific
cases, you can deal with the
nonlinearities. But so often,
the techniques I know about are
linearizing, somehow. And that's
where I took it back to the
first one was, when you
linearize inactive subspaces
you're averaging over some some
space? How can you do that for
parameter subset selection. And
the reason one of the reasons
after talking with you, I've
wanted to show those math
biology examples. But this is
really important here. Because
the nonlinearities, in some of
these, these math, biology
models are tremendously. They're
very nonlinear, there's delays,
etc. And commonly is
nonlinearities is a big deal.
And so I think there's a lot of
work to be done for working with
the truly nonlinear models when
we have to keep track of the
nonlinear narratives. I mean,
that's just always the case when
you linearize is, gosh, what are
you losing in the process?
Nicely? Thank you, Rob. There's
a question in the chat room. By
Boyer. He's asking, Can the
active subspace approach be
applied to general regression
problem to do variable selection
or variable importance ranking?
Yeah, no, broadly, it can. And
one of the things that let me
see if I can go back really,
really quickly is active
subspaces does give you these
activity scores. And thank you,
I love these kinds of do give
you a measure of global
sensitivity. And so you can't
get a measure of global
sensitivity. There's relations
and bounced between these and
Sobel indices. So you can get
global sensitivity rankings and
use that for parameter
selection. And still go into
original space, but but the
answer is yes. And work in the
original nonlinear space. I
showed what happens when we find
a subspace of values, but you
can use this to just rank
parameters. So great question.
Probably didn't emphasize that
enough. But that's where we
looked at the activity scores.
Thank you. Thank you, Rob.
Is there any other question from
audiences?
Have a question. Hi, Ralph. This
is Mark transfrom. Here. Yeah.
How
are you, Mark?
I'm doing great. It's very nice
talk. Thank you very much. Oh,
my gosh, it's
so good to get back with with
this group. Thank you.
So I was kind of struck by the
plot, you showed that had the
the eigenvalues of the the C
matrix that comes out of the
active subspace analysis, where
you have the very large gap that
you can clearly see, these are
the things that matter. And
there's a clear distinction
between the active and the
inactive, the important to the
unimportant. And so much of my
other work in looking at
eigenvalues, the Fisher
information matrices, where we
talked about sloppy analysis, we
see plots that sort of look like
this, but we often see
eigenvalue spread over many
orders of magnitude without a
gap anywhere. Oh, my gosh, yes,
we always have this problem.
There's obviously things that
are unimportant. But there's no
clear distinction between the
important and the unimportant.
And so that's the question that
we the dilemma that we're always
grappling with. And I'm just
curious if you have any
experience similar experiences
with that, or insights into how
you would handle such a
scenario?
Oh, my gosh, yeah, Mark, I love
questions like that. Because,
yes, we have exactly the same
experience. This one was
obvious. There it is both. And
we also this one, where we did
this one was pretty obvious.
However, when we do these types
of examples for the math
biology, it's exactly what you
see, you see a decay in singular
values. And then you start
saying, is that a gap? Or is
that really not? And so the best
thing I so yes, we've seen it,
it comes up on these math
biology examples a lot. The best
thing I know to do on that, and
this is we, as in Kamal has been
doing a lot of this as saying,
Okay, let's start fixing,
there's obvious parameters to
fix, we fix those. And then we
do some kind of a verification
stuff where we randomly perturb
parameters, all of the
parameters and those that are
fixed. And we see if we get the
same distributions, or you can
quantify this using energy
statistics. And please send me
email if you'd like more
information on the energies to
see. But yeah, we definitely
seen the scenarios that you're
pointing out. And the best that
I know to do on that is, say,
Okay, we've got to go in, and
then let's start working our way
down into those less clear
parameters, fix them, vary our
response, see what we get. And
that kind of a verification
step, either qualitative or
quantitative? is the only way I
know to answer that at this
point. But you're right, it
comes up at it. It's something
we see a lot on these. And
perhaps this kind of goes back
to your question. Earlier, very
nonlinear models. Yes, it does
come up. And the best I know is
to try and do that kind of a
verification. Thank you. Thank
you. Thank you for pointing that
out. Because, yeah, I made it
look so obvious. And those were
best cases, on these problems,
you really have to get into this
sort of gray regime. And you
then have to go through
parameter by parameter in some
cases, and just test it. Great,
thanks.
Thank you, Ron. There's one more
question. Do you have a time,
I've got plenty of time on my
next meeting is not for an hour,
I made sure to leave a polite
time slot here. This is i This
is the kind of the highlight of
the day is talking with you
guys. Let's go with questions.
All right. Sounds good. Okay,
another question from Marco. He
says, Great talk, do you have
some experience in using slides
the inverse regression SAR for
this kind of problems? To
identify subspaces?
I don't. And my request Marko is
please send me a reference on
that. I'd love to see more about
it. And this kind of goes for
everybody. Please, if you've got
questions, things that I'm the
only Smith in mathematics at
NCSU. I'm easy to find. I know
several of you. But I'd love to
see references in it. I'm afraid
I'm not familiar with it. And
I'd love to see references. So
please send me email and let's
communicate. I'd love to see
what you're more about that.
Sounds good. One of the
motivations of this, this talk
is to, you know, the facilitate
more collaboration with you and
the folks in Lawrence Livermore
National Lab. So actually, I saw
the you know, you know, in the
beginning slides there you have
the collaboration with the
Sandia National Lab and Los
Alamos but you're missing
Lawrence live on us and you got
to do a better job.
I did one of the reasons I was
thrilled when you contacted me
to speak for many, many reasons
that are just thrilled and so
honored, but one of them is I'd
love to keep building those
collaborations. And the reason
for the Sandia, Lawrence
Livermore, or I'm sorry, Sandia,
and go back to the beginning was
Los Alamos was these DoD
initiatives. And so a lot of
that was that came out of the
DoD initiatives, but no I,
Lawrence Livermore a again, I've
I've got some some very well,
former students and very close
colleagues there. I'd love to
keep building these
collaborations. That was one of
the reasons I was so grateful
when you you contacted me to
speak. So thank you.
Yeah, that's great. That's
great. All right. Any other
questions? From audience?
I think we were folks out well,
gosh, again, thank you so much
for the chance to visit and
speak with you and please,
please, let's use this to step
one to let's start communicating
via email, zoom, etc. And let's,
let's see what we might be able
to build on collaborations.
Yeah, let's do that. Okay. Thank
you so much. Let's, you know,
give a applause to our speaker
of it was a great honor to host
you. And, yeah, thank you very
much. Let's keep in touch.
That sounds perfect. Well, that
sounds wonderful. Let's keep in
touch and then meanwhile, have a
wonderful holiday season,
everyone.
Likewise, likewise. Yeah, care.
Thanks, all. Thank you.
Bye